[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like I've been walking in the sky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning chest don't be alarmed
there's no one filling in for me it is
me I did trim my hair yesterday kind of
dramatic I know I'm looking like way
different so don't freak out if you're
watching on the live stream it's me you
know like your birthday November 6 1992
how would I know that if it wasn't me
yeah no I was confused I'm not gonna
like if you look so radically different
I know I cut a good two and a half
inches off my hair and I'm just feeling
lightweight he also like thinned it out
like he like shed some of my hair it was
the craziest thing to watch because he
was like picking it up he's like it's
heavy I'm like so much so you're feeling
weightless I'm feeling weight less yes I
it looks exactly the same it's crazy but
that's it that's what you want out of a
haircut like you want I would be like
look a little different you wanted the
desk on but you want to keep the link
that's everyone's dream so I'm glad I
honestly didn't even notice I know but
you know what they say what's dead may
never die right until it's on the floor
a hair salon
you can't what said may never die I
finally finished the game of Thrones
documentary like about the show no one I
thought everyone had watched it I'm sure
of it quite interest on they have this
one storyline about this guy who's an
extra who's like [ __ ] ride-or-die
Game of Thrones and he plays a stark um
a stark man like a northerner a
northerner and he's in the stark army
and he like [ __ ] loves the Starks and
like he's so invested in like this
storyline that he actually coaches the
other extras like I asked what's going
on well you know we would kill
Lannisters but here we're not supposed
to be killing Lannister so we're
conflicted like and the documentary like
started to focus on him more and more
and it was so freakin cute by the end
but so you don't have to watch the
documentary but just that one tidbit and
then the show ends and he's like crying
and can't like hiring him and so many
people come up to him and they're like
oh I think you do you'll be like made
like so you made such an impact um and
then after the show now he does Game of
Thrones tours um and he talks about
where they shot and like shows scenes
where he's in the back literally like
the bartender from bachelor in paradise
yes he's war Hey that's so funny I
thought it was a really like sweet thing
and I
nobody else had seen know I haven't
heard about it but thanks for sharing
that sounds quite interesting
yeah I meant to watch and now that you
know that the cute the one key part like
you don't really need to watch it yeah I
really don't like seeing how the sauce
gets me I know my I agree and it's like
the actor is like Santa has air pods in
like that just doesn't work though I
don't know that actually ruins the
fantasy look she has her sanso hair and
then like a bright blue robe on no
that's not a Z Bed Bath & Beyond robe I
know I've told you both about this show
and like you first watch it but working
moms it's the best show on TV okay and
by the way I'm not the only one who
raced I made Olivia and Zach watch it i
dinner with them last night and Olivia
said she loved it and Zach was like
we're obsessed with it I'm like the new
season came out here we go we already
watched it I'm taking it real slow
because it's like short episodes and
there's only ten and like I really want
to enjoy it but it's really it's the
best show oh I wonder watch it I was
actually last night looking for a new
show which is why I wound up finishing
the documentary that I started on the
plane it's easy it's 22 minute episodes
like it's just and it's enjoy all takes
place in Tirana you get to know a new
city ooh yeah it's actually just like a
great show you know what else I watched
while I was scouring the depths of all
my TV apps for some premium content
Camila Mendes did a video with Vogue
about her now cute yeah I thought it was
kind of interesting I thought it was
cute like and I was glad that though
respected the hell out of Riverdale you
know meet you but I just felt like it
was such a dumb video yeah she gets her
nails done I think the whole premise
memory Heather McDonald was on the toast
but she was on the breath la week she
was talking about how anytime with
celebrity gets interviewed in like a
major magazine the journalist always
makes it a point to be like and the
celebrity was so nice to the word trust
like as if that's like something
revolutionary I need to tell like the
whole video was look Tammy members is so
nice to Everett ness lon oh no when I
watched videos she spends the whole day
alone but where are all her friends I
don't know oh we saw Charles Melton in
every minute yeah that was cute that was
cute
you know he's a real cutie when you
think about how he's like shot to
stardom only because Ross Butler to
renew his contract as Reggie in
Riverdale like that's so crazy and
honestly one of the biggest mistakes
ever like I know Ross Butler still in 13
reasons why I'm at 13 me since why is
not even close to being as big as
Riverdale yeah one man's trash is
another man's treasure who's another
man's man
Daario naharis
right makes you think makes you think I
watched one other thing yesterday that I
had wanted to talk about but it has now
evaded me well it is Friday so that
already is just like an exciting feeling
but it's being elevated even more
because literally like maybe my favorite
person alive but both of our favorite
person alive is joining us today Becca
Tobin you might know now where as kitty
from Glee but you probably know her as
one third of the lady gang lady game TV
living podcast lady game towards the
lady hang um just like a lady game kind
of week do you get like a pit when we
have like a great guest coming I mean of
course I was in bed at 9:30 I had dinner
with Olivia and Zach and I was just like
in bed with like a full belly watching
working moms and Theo like I was so
happy
then Brian texted me he's like never in
town and he was like I came back early
like let's like come up drinking my new
apartment and like I like I really
wanted to stay in bed but like I knew
it's the right thing to do like I never
got to see Brian and I was like
literally like not being fun I'm like I
can't look sorry like I Becca Tobin on
the toast where it like interview of a
lifetime and no truly like this is gonna
be a two-hour show because between like
lady getting podcast drama and then like
the Glee of it all I just have so much
to [ __ ] talk to her about hallmark of
it all oh right so if you have a
question for Becca Tobin like you're
dying for us to ask please go to our
Instagram right now we posted a picture
of her last night throughout the comment
there was something to be taking
questions from that and asking back up
yeah it's it's gonna be a good one but I
do get like so nervous I always have a
pit I always have it with me like a good
sort of pit when we have a guest I guess
with a job but when it's like premium as
hell I'm just like she was under
literally one of the biggest TV shows of
all time like but we've had other Gleeks
but it's like the it's the Glee plus the
podcast the current state of Becca Tobin
yeah you know I just wonder what she's
doing in New York Fashion Week
probably so many that's right when it
rains it pours so many people are in New
York this week because of Fashion Week
by the way she's probably why we've had
so many guys Oh 100% should we do a live
unboxing of your skins order scheme
stuff hi skins I think I'm at it right
now yeah yeah like maybe came over you
posted or something I don't know okay
yeah go grab it try to put stuff on no I
mean you can if that would be it's not
usually that kind of show and I could go
off come back I'm down no that's would
you ever like my outfit too much so mine
got delivered Jackie's got delivered to
the studio but mine got delivered to
you go walking French um here we go eh
eh hey hey okay so by the way like when
this bag came to reception like all the
girls in the office we're like screaming
oh you weren't here like four girls came
in there like skims they brought it to
us and they were like schemes to open it
I'm like I can it's not mine oh my god a
huge bag he told me yesterday it arrived
yesterday but it was after we had left
the studio can they see I just wanna
make sure everyone oh you have to stand
up the oilskin and I think it's the real
like PR one that can put on her store ya
know by the way um you have to keep this
bag of course this is my new father
jealous
no stop it okay sorry I'm like annoyed
that I don't love it so but it's huge
heavy so does she send you all the
shades no all the different products but
this is just the box but then these are
I guess are all the shades oh but you
bet I look at my sizes Wow so like
here's one what's a good I think I told
them I'm a medium on bottom small on top
these are small medium that is my size
I ordered a large extra large oh okay I
just want it I want to talk about the
material feels very soft and very
elastic like and it has that band up top
so it doesn't roll over yeah I'm like
but it also doesn't look like it's gonna
cut you like a knife oh my god I cannot
believe that like you're gonna fit into
this I know
stop what it's oh sorry I'm excited
please oh oh you're me get my now don't
be [ __ ] rude no but that's really
don't trust my skin's that's right I
don't have oh happy oh these are my
favorite kind of underwear high powered
panties but it's a thought but it's a
thong this is literally what I'm wearing
right now except like not with as good
of material you've a high waisted thong
yeah all of my most half of my thongs
are high waisted and half our low-rise
depending on what I'm wearing on the
bottom by the way this is not sponsored
like I should know it's make that
cleared
we wish it's def sponsor sponsored with
love okay Brizzy er oh I don't know if
these are gonna fit my bro you got big
jugs yes it's not sure might might be a
snitches bounty Wow how exciting
this is what's tougher music cuz they
just asked for my size arbitrarily and I
gave them my bra size for real but it's
like I'm a small on top because I'm very
narrow but my breasts are massive so a
small brassiere won't come I wonder if
it a large one I guess won't fit me
either I wonder if they're gonna end up
selling in like a Bloomingdale's and
Macy's I feel like they really should
you know what I have a wedding this
weekend and literally this I needed to
like go and refill my control tops away
but now Here I am
the second thing that you would like
hosiery Department is truly like a such
as Paris these are the ones that go all
the way down me I want to see the ones
that are well alike yeah yeah Wow oh my
god I'm set for life with this no truly
that high power I went T's soul coverage
Wow Wow there's something for everyone
you guys high power Oh even higher power
panties I love my neck I live for a high
powered penny moment and last but not
least half shorts no [ __ ] no I guess I
didn't get them leotard I actually truly
need this I already love a leotard I
love a leotard when I was in college I
used to wear Spanx leotard under
everything like it was my bra and I
think it did a lot for my shapes um so
I'm Kim I was gonna say him I'm really
happy for her that she like got this
brand out and about like to the masses
within like a weeks of just changing the
name you know otally
like they had this box and they were
just waiting to put this on top right
Wow I think I'm gonna like just lay this
in my home because not only is it like
art but it's an accomplishment
I agree an Emmy well great happy freak I
influenced my way into getting a PR
package from Kim Kardashian like you
know actually to get k'kaw beauty a few
years ago no you did but you had
influenced your way like it's my first
Kardashian PR package I just I like to
feel like it's worth noting like I go
into it's like at my apartment okay no
but like you we all know that like she's
not you you're like I just want everyone
to like I'm cool also no but we all like
no you're very cool like 3 million
followers your employee no it's Jackie
it's a huge hump like and you know I'm
just like micro influencing over here
and I just I feel seen and
I just want to thank him and the whole
games team I'm actually like so happy
for you like you're like it's so sad
like this means a lot to us of all of
the like things that she sells for me to
receive this is actually the most for me
because her makeup doesn't um like we
don't have nearly the same coloring over
like this I truly need I'm going to a
wedding like I have a gut but the
branding is very like on on point yeah
and I have to be honest like feeling
that stuff you never know until you put
it on but like it feels like a dream
yeah I think it's gonna be great and I'm
you know what maybe I'll like post some
photos because apparently I'm so brave
with my story towel today oh my god your
Instagram stories in a towel yesterday
I'm like this [ __ ] is gonna flash you
too but you know that I didn't because I
posted it he's like so it's like
exciting but sometimes you're like crazy
like every now and then you'll do
something like wild and I thought like
maybe this [ __ ] is gonna flash this
yeah like maybe she was so inspired by
her patroness ode of like influencing
our way to the top where they talk about
our favorite influencers and I was like
gonna do anything for more followers
great new episode on patreon channel
patreon.com session morning to us we
went through our Instagram and like all
the people we follow that we like really
recommend yeah and like why we follow
them how we started following them cuz
you can tell a lot about someone by who
they thought was it's a good episode I
didn't think it was gonna be good but I
was wrong
yeah as usual I was wrong I think the
toasters really enjoyed it also I think
as usual like we pulled it out you know
yeah you know we could pull a Doody out
of a butthole right it's never like the
topic we just need a topic and then from
there we just start talking um so I
think it's it's a good amount of time
because you know we got lots of stuff to
do lots of people to chat with I believe
additionally I think so I don't know yes
I think I think okay sure go no you know
my turn it is time for the test I don't
know who I am anymore I really [ __ ] us
up no oh yeah it's time for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast oh you like that
you're too good to do your job now that
you've got some skins yeah it's like I'm
I guess I'm all done okay I reach the
top yeah stop climbing so well it would
seem like today's episode is brought to
you by skins it's definitely not because
it's brought to you by talk space talk
spaces therapy for how we live today
it's mobile it's available when you need
it and it's affordable life can be
stressful between work family and
everything in between it's not always
easy to find time for yourself talk
space online therapy makes taking care
of your mental health more affordable
and convenient than ever
or simply provide your preferences for
therapy and tops base will match you
with one of their 5,000 therapists the
very same day send your therapist
unlimited text audio picture or video
messages from anywhere at any time no
matter where you're going through you're
not alone it's convenient and easy to
use and most importantly it's affordable
one month of therapy on the tops place
talk space platform cost about the same
amount as a single face-to-face session
best of all you'll never have to wait a
week to share what's on your mind top
space is more than 5,000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing the challenges we all face to
match up your perfect therapists in a
fraction of the price of traditional
therapy go to tot space.com make sure
you use the code toast to get sixty five
dollars off your first month and show
support for the show that's toast at top
space comm so the link is talk space
comm if you want to use code toast I
feel like that's genius like I can't
believe we have it like that hasn't
happened sooner I know it's like
economical but it's also technologically
savvy for the world that we live in
agree you know it's very apropos very
apropos especially for Millennials good
morning good morning okay
first story um really crazy and I this
is the official first official photo
that we've gotten of Tyler Cameron and
Gigi Hadid at her grandmother's funeral
in the Netherlands where he accompanied
her because he is her man yeah and I
feel like people really glazed over the
fact like dual if I was there too you
know he's right sorry Tyler she takes
the cake but like interesting that on
we're into a lip our like serious enough
that she would also go to the
Netherlands no I thought the same thing
I was like oh who's that woman I'm like
is that to a weapon like no one's
noticing cuz the runner-up from The
Bachelor is there right and also like
Bella is snitch yeah v wheeling yes but
also the most interesting part of this
entire story I'm about to shake the
toasters world yeah I went to post this
picture on Instagram because I could
ship me up and I wanted to be like the
first person to get the TMZ photo and I
tagged everyone and I couldn't find
Bella in the toast Instagram so I just
posted it and I noticed I'm like I
cannot find Bella Hadid on the toastie
Instagram and I don't know why and then
I go I'm like she delete her Instagram
so I go on girl with no job and she's
right there and that's coming to the
conclusion that Bella Hadid blocked the
toast makes you think and then we were
thinking like what could she have
blocked us from and I'm sure like
probably tagged her in something where
we called her like fell off a feed right
I'm sorry she probably just like blocks
accounts that like meme her and
like talk [ __ ] because yeah who want to
see that she can because she can yeah I
respect it yeah we miss you yeah you can
unblock whatever you want and you're
also always welcome on the show um so
this is like the definition of
bittersweet news because their
grandmother has passed away but we got
we start like photo confirmation and by
the way everyone looks like they're in
good spirits considering the the dead
right so um I they look like one big
happy family and I'm so happy for know
there's meshing well we are medically he
started following the cousins on
Instagram and it's like it's all it's
all happening I mean the question now is
like would you take someone to your
grandmother's funeral who you have
allegedly been dating for two weeks but
now there's so much speculation about
you know you take someone to to a
funeral when you're so far along in your
relationship like were they dating long
before we knew is that is that what
people are saying yeah yeah hyaline now
does it make sense if they really went
on a couple dates like last week no it
wasn't last week honestly we've been
talking about this now for at least a
month I know time flies when you're a
prestigious morning show host it's like
we started talking about it when the
snacks are dropped which was we've done
for five episodes that's five weeks
that's over a month no I think okay it's
still like a month and your grandma's
funeral like flying to the Netherlands
no I agreed that it's super quick I
think they've been together every single
day like this is where relationships get
tested he goes to the bachelor he fell
in love in a month and they're living
like that timeline right now so you do
not agree with some of the speculation
like maybe they were dating or like
seeing each other a lot like while the
season was airing but I really kept it
low Kate
maybe it's starting at best maybe it
started a week or two before we knew
because that friend was saying like he's
texting models
remember that yep yeah and so but like
texting he didn't say hanging out with
dating so maybe we were a few days or a
week behind but I don't think it was
while the season was airing yes I just
feel like when you're a celebrity you
don't have to adhere to like normal
dating no tocall like you like you type
like me alone and Tyler wanted to come
like you have a job life in the fast
lane applies to everyone I agree he
doesn't have a job but did you see a
toaster found yes oh my god that was the
most premium thing someone posted in the
toasters group that she was walking out
on the street
basically when you go into any office
building in New York you have to check
in at reception and the big fancy
buildings like take a little picture of
you and then put it on this sticker you
have to wear the stick around the
building it has your picture and like
the company that you're going to and
someone was walking around New York
yesterday and found on the street a
sticker a guest sticker for IMG modeling
agency with a picture of Tyler on it
said Tyler scary yeah crazy are you
captain
so I guess like he's signing with IMG
potentially yeah we've gotten that Intel
on the snapshot Instagram a while ago
that he's gonna be like a major face of
Calvin Klein yeah it's all
unsubstantiated but this IMG thing maybe
I don't want to say it because I didn't
know if I don't want to just talk out of
my ass but now this IMG thing really
makes a lot of sense because all the
Calvin Klein models are from imj yeah
and like like that's the biggest
modeling agency I am an IMG client no
technically we are think about where a
beautiful was Tyler saying that was that
was a crazy that was really like put
into perspective for me when I saw that
picture of my glass celebrities can't do
anything no not at all not even drop
something on the street without selling
it back to your conspiracy theory about
were they dating earlier unless we not
forget to sleep over it of it also games
like ABC just made him do it you think a
thousand percent I don't think in any
way was that I don't know that it was
necessarily like heat they like were
trying to rekindle things but maybe he
was I don't think he would play that
game if he's dating Gigi Hadid he's he's
he doesn't he's not obligated to take a
picture he didn't he like told Gigi like
oh hey I got to do this and she's like
right I sure think that sleepover
picture between Hannah Tyler was
completely manufactured yeah yeah but
like why would he participate in that if
he has gigi hadid on the other line
because he probably had an obligation
that's not in his contract those ABC
contracts are crazy
ironclad hmm okay okay I'm gonna need
some more information before I pass
judgment I just think what we're seeing
from Tyler see and Gigi is very much
real but I do think there's probably a
lot of behind the scenes stuff that like
we don't know about so I'm trying to
figure out and I just want to know like
and maybe one day when they get married
have kids in like you know do a podcast
they'll talk about how they first met
and like who each out to hey like I want
to know if she saw him on TV she was
like having mine with the girls and she
was like why can't I date a guy like
that and then they were like you can
you're Gigi and so she message
you know imagine just like wanting
anything and getting it do you know what
I mean but then it's like she can get a
date with anyone she wants sure but like
to be in a relationship with someone you
actually like have to have chemistry and
like a connection he seems like a
genuine guy so like I don't think he
would just like hang around to go to the
Netherlands funeral right um so I think
the fact that they're still together
it just shows like they're meant to be
you know I mean like what if they get
married like that'll be so please like
to me this is as crazy like same level
of crazy like could never wouldn't
believe it if you told it to me as Megan
Merkel and Prince Harry one thousand
percent like it's an amazing analogy
it's colliding how did these people meet
who what when where why how like I just
never believed it if you told me a year
ago yeah ever that's Gigi Hadid is gonna
date a bachelor contestant Chucky I'm
1,000% on the same page and but I'm so
here for it no me too I thanks great
Prince Harry is gonna marry a Hallmark
star also I kind of say it's a Hallmark
dream come true in a lot of our eyes
this is a great PR move for gigi hadid
like she's being spoken about now more
than ever and this is like really
humanizing her I feel like she purred
like a long time it's like untouchable
like in this realm of supermodel that
like no one can even touch but like now
she's dating someone like one of us
could've dated you know she's just a
regular girl like I think it was
actually a brilliant PR move like and
she's like not not on purpose I feel as
though she's living her best life this
summer like her and Bella like drunk at
the VMAs drunk at the US Open just like
having a ball and now she is like a man
on harm I think she's in a great place
and I'm so happy for her know like I
used to look at pictures of her and be
like damn it doesn't look fun to be a
supermodel but she works so hard she
looked so unhealthy for a while like she
was like running herself down and I was
like honestly I would never want to be a
supermodel now like being a supermodel
means go to the BMA it's like okay I'm
down you know yeah totally I guess we
gotta get into modeling you know in the
words of Amy Schumer like for a lot of
people like it's like a calling for me
it's just like an option you know
totally okay next up Nicki Minaj says
tweet about retirement was quote abrupt
I'm still right here she says so
yesterday Nicki Minaj tweeted that she
was retiring she said she's gonna she's
done it and she wants to start a family
yeah but then she deleted the tweet and
said I'm still right here still madly in
love with you guys and you know that in
hindsight this should have been it suck
a queen radio discussion
it will be I promise you guys will be
happy no guests just us talking about
everything the tweet was abrupt and
insensitive I apologize babe
so is reading her tweets today and even
though she deleted the original one I
was under the impression that she still
is very much retiring but she now wants
to give her fans like more of an
official send-off and like some closure
yeah and there was a lot of discussion
on the toast Instagram and in the toast
groups about this because a lot of
people are just like wondering if like
she was pushed out like if this is a
decision she came to on her own or won
because like the world feels like cardi
B has very much replaced Nicki Minaj and
I know that and there there should be
and I know that there is room for more
than one female rapper in the game but I
feel like Nicki Minaj over the years
I've made it a very unwelcoming
environment for a lot of girls and cardi
B was like the one person who like
penetrated beyond that I don't know what
like have any facts without that's just
like the way that I proceed did like
yeah that she's been like are we
starting beef like with her mama yeah
and like no one ever even came close to
being as big as Nicki Minaj because like
she it wasn't the type of environment
where was like let's build up each other
do you mean
yeah no I get that I don't I don't know
I feel like she's just like saying stuff
to say it but like I pretend I feel as
though when you're an artist like and
you make music it's like you don't
choose to it chooses you yeah like if
she's you don't just turn it on and off
yeah like she's not just gonna stop
making me second like I don't want to I
know I mean I know we have to like take
sides here and hit women against each
other because that's what we do at this
show but I and I love cardi B and like
if I gun to my head its cardi B but I
really like Nikki you actually like her
music and I don't want her to go
anywhere I hope she doesn't feel like
she like lost something I have like over
the past few years like really started
to dislike Nicki Minaj when I was like a
Stan like I knew other words to super
bass and like I thought she was like
amazing mean the only female rapper like
she was so cool with her eggs and I
watched a documentary I just like really
started to just like her because of all
like the the drama she creates like
outside of her music like it's just so
annoying to me and like I just feel like
she's always like looking for attention
in the sense of like starting drama with
people and they just I just every time I
read about her in the news I'm like
disagreeing with the spite she's
starting I completely agree with that
and it's like it's a letter and I even
feel like this retirement comment it's
just like tension but it's like she's
not retiring like I feel like maybe
she's pulling an ed sheeran taking a
break focusing on family which is fine
but you're not retiring okay so if you
say retiring you're never making music
again right is what you're saying I
don't know but then when I was thinking
about it I'm like damn this is ideal
situation like homegirl made her coin
now she's married
alright he's a sex offender but whatever
and now she just want to start a family
like doesn't have to work like that's
the dream like you put in a lot of work
for like 15 years and then you live off
the fruits of your labor like with your
baby daddy and your and your kids yeah
that is the dream like I saw both sides
that I'm like honestly I totally feel
that call up like your priorities where
your work now it's a different timing
life or your priorities family but I
don't know same I has to be zero or 60
and I mean I'm like the definition of
zero or 60 but shouldn't there be like
30 where it's like okay I'm gonna rich
I'm gonna focus on family work less but
you can still put out albums you can
have a studio in your house and you just
don't tour them like via calling it the
word retire is dramatic because it's
probably like if she didn't join a
country club and golf every day it's a
break it's a break like is she gonna hit
her retirement fund up no I'm I wonder
how much money she has yeah she's like
now that I think about it like and it
sucks that I'm like over her because she
really like changed she's not even
changed she created the female rapping
game like she's actually an icon like no
one either even ever came close like
that Iggy Azalea song for a minute we
were like is she gonna do it then like
she didn't and she is an icon and
deserves respect but I just feel like
she didn't evolve like with the times
like I feel like when she started it was
like yeah women being competitive then
it's like no we're all friends we in the
words of Taylor Swift we all got crowns
and I don't know I feel like Nicki Minaj
like never embodied that yeah like she
never like there was a timer it was like
cool the pit women against the other and
now it's like very cool to embrace and
support and respect the hell out of
women um and I think if she had embraced
cardi be on her way up she being maybe a
little bit of a different spot um but
she stuck to her guns and you know what
I respect that to me too it's like when
we were saying yesterday about like
Mariah Carey being a diva and like
everyone knows she's a diva and like
that's her thing I think nicki minaj is
the same way but just for some reason
like people don't respect it you know
maybe that's pointing because she's
unapologetically herself
yeah Mike Harry shades people all the
time I don't know her no yeah and I
think it's funny yeah that's a good
point that's an unfair uh double
standard
I agree so anyways I just hope whatever
she's doing that she's happy I really
hope she joins a country club like
that's what one should be doing went on
a break and when you're rich yeah but
like she I also just want to tell her
like you can join a country club and
still work right I mean we can't but
right you can I will I will retire when
I can afford a country like a nice
country club like that's when I know I
like your career achievement is the
skims mine is a Country Club ya know my
career achievement like to know that I'm
a big and I like that I've made it as a
star bona fide star would be just with
the standards if it stars then I know
that someone thinks I'm a star I my name
is Netflix special so it looks like
we'll both be here for a while
yeah and also like I said watch what
happens live it said that's just that's
just you know gravy yeah those are just
steps at the top like I'm at the top of
the hill has a few more steps
that's a pretty bring your own today oh
my gosh thank you I just got it you know
I'm not a huge jewelry person but we
started working with alright on this
show and I got this ring it is to match
my wedding ring cuz now I'm like Amos oh
they're cute
cuz all my jewelry used to be gold but
now I wanted more silver stuff so I've
been on all right like finding the
cutest things like rings bracelets
earrings necklaces you can do custom
they have their own designs and I want
to tell the twisters more about it
alright is fine jewelry made in New York
City founded by women for women pieces
range from classic to statement to
completely original or it makes the
jewelry you've always wanted but can
never find it's insanely good quality
their gold feel substantial and the
diamonds sparkle and shine very high
quality and super beautiful it's a low
price but for high quality because or
eight sells directly to you without the
middleman markup they can offer the same
quality as traditional fifth avenue
brands but at a fraction of the cost and
the best part is that for every piece
sold you're doing good a child in need
receives a book to further their
education or it was started by two
friends during brunch when one of them
got a green finger from an overpriced
ring sparking conversation about how
they were fed up with the traditional
jewelry market it's fine with me oh
that's so relatable it's by women for
women if you want to you know join in on
the fun for 15% off your first or a
purchase go to or eat new york.com slash
toast and use promo code toast
so that's a you are a te new york.com /
toast or rate or rate new york.com /
toast that's a good one that is a good
one I think it's very super toasty and
the testers will love it yeah I'm loving
my ring I would ask to try it on but
like maybe that sausage fingers I just
like I hope they carry my size you know
they have so many sizes like from my
ring my fingers actually happen to be
really small they had as small as me Wow
yeah okay next story a bit of Demi
Lovato news because she is getting super
honest on Instagram she posted an
unedited bikini photo and said this is
my biggest fear a photo of me in a
bikini unedited and guess like guess
what
it's sell you lit I don't know if she
meant to spell so she's like she's okay
it's sell you lit okay cool I'm just
literally so tired of being ashamed of
my body editing it yes the other bikini
pics were edited and I hate that I did
that but that's the truth so that others
think I'm their idea of what beautiful
is but it's just not me this is what I
got I want this new chapter in my life
to be about being authentic to who I am
we rather than trying to meet someone
else's standards so here's me unashamed
unafraid and proud to own a body that
has fought through so much and will
continue to amaze me when I hopefully
give birth Monday okay
sorry Margo left the room and she you
just slam her computer shut this mantle
just lost her job oh my god this is a
live show this snitch she was an editor
her earpods playing the toast on her
computer and then she left the room to
go get becca and earpods must have
disconnected but like how dare she
yeah so if you're a PA in the New York
area if you're a PA in the New York area
um definitely reach out it's like
working with her like well write her a
letter of recommendation oh really I
won't okay okay I was on a big train of
thought with them Margot how dare you
you don't know what you just did your
aunt pods disconnected cuz you walked
away with that and your computer was
blasting so pack your things
type up Thank You PA take your plan to
put it in the box though that lady's
ours it's okay
you know what she liked
okay she said now back to the studio I'm
working on an anthem also just so
everyone's clear I'm out
stoked on my appearance but I'm
appreciative of it and sometimes that's
the best that I can do I hope to inspire
someone to appreciate their body today
too
this is the most brave thing ever not
only just like baring yourself for the
world but admitting that like past
photos have all been edited like that is
so brave and I just have to say like I
don't have any proof but like I feel
like this shift in Demi Lovato and just
in like the world it stems from one
thing
Scooter Braun Lizza she's changing the
world I'm telling you I could just feel
it I feel as though she's changing the
world but I'm gonna bring it back to
Demi here because she's been through so
much emotionally physically like her
life it's just an her career it's always
on the up and down even when she's up
like it's never suck guys are high and
the lows or the eyes are never even
certain for her like every day is a
battle for her and she's just always
doing the best that she can and I think
not only like does she look amazing and
she should be so proud of herself but
like this really is inspiring because so
many people post on Instagram like my
stretch marks from when I was pregnant
but like nobody posts they're just like
average 24 year old girls cellulite sigh
yeah like and I have it too and I'm not
gonna lie like I would never never us is
making me reconsider things then she was
reposing on her story like lavada --kx
tape with their bikini pictures and
their cellulite and I was like that's
what I look like and I just want to
maybe I'm not there yet but like one day
I will get to that one no you're sure
I'm not there but I thought this was
like so brave and so inspiring and like
I definitely stand Demi Lovato I did
before but now I definitely I definitely
do a little bit more and by the way she
looks great also I want to talk about
cellulite for a second because it is
just the craziest thing because thin
people have cellulite bigger people have
cellulite and like it doesn't you don't
choose cellulite cellulite chooses you
like there's nothing that you can eat
there's nothing you can do to make
cellulite okay so not a weight thing
because very thin people have it and
then bigger people don't have it
sometimes right so it's like there's
nothing you can do about it so like why
are we so hard on our
for having cellulite no it's honestly
like I don't mind myself like I think
it's kind of cute I don't want my
cellulite in the bathing suit because
I'm like here I am I'm human but like
when I'm running close in like my thighs
cellulite like in jean shorts I'm like
sad ya know and it's you know what it is
there's no cure for cell you know there
is none I saw like the one and only
episode of Oprah I ever saw she said
there is no cure for cellulite like
everything that's like this will
kick-start your cellulite is a lie yeah
and just you got to live with it and so
the best we can do is embrace it no it's
this was demi lovato just took like four
big steps for body positivity
I completely Greek it's like no one I
mean Kim sometimes says it but even she
gets so bogged down by it but like no
one's fighting the cellulite fight yeah
you know we typically yeah specifically
cellulite agreed so I just as someone
who like has cellulite and it's just
like getting rapidly increasing by the
day I really related to this and I think
it was super brave and I think she looks
amazing and it's so did Mike Johnson who
is like in her comments well so that's
the other thing it's like everyone
there's so much speculation because
every time she posts on Instagram like
he post something flirty but that
doesn't mean anything obviously he's
gonna be posting on her Instagram she's
[ __ ] Tammy Lovato he's my Johnson you
know right so him commenting doesn't
mean anything if I saw some reciprocated
comments back then I would start to
think something yes Mitch what's been
the like has there been back and forth
between demi and mike johnson just like
on comment just but him commenting or
her commenting to her commenting back
yeah oh because she like loved hannah
season and me and mike commented on one
of Tyler C's Instagram about a double
date I saw that so I imagine it's like
GG Debbie like my johnson's like trying
to make him and Demi like yeah I'm like
Tyler and Gigi like it's not the same
but it's close if they were to date I
would completely [ __ ] but I have
something controversial to say now that
I've been like looking at Mike
Charlatans comments like excited for
something and we follow him on Twitter
so I see his tweets and like his
comments and tweets like don't make a
ton of sense no he's like the type of
person who's like cool in person but
like has a weird Internet person has a
you're an internet personality and it
just it just dawned on me that's the
worst like when you know someone or like
you meet them and you really like them
then you like
they're weird Instagram activity and
like it makes you second-guess them like
why are you being a freak yeah and I
feel like he's always talking to Dylan
on Twitter and I'm like I can't tell if
you guys like each other or not because
I don't know what these tweets those
your jokes like aren't funny because
your jokes aren't funny yeah and it's
just making me go back to what the
toaster posted that Chris Harrison had
said about Mike that he wouldn't make a
good bachelor and now I'm like seeing it
you're not unclear yeah and it's making
a lot of sense why he literally hasn't
gotten one moment of airtime on bachelor
in paradise because I think he might be
like a weirdo I think so too
also new episode of the snaps are
available on iTunes and Spotify if you
want to check it out we've recapped this
week a bachelor in paradise
not a lot went on but a lot went out on
our podcast and we do dive into like
what happened to Mike Johnson yeah and I
think at the end of the day he just
suffered from a case of Benzi syndrome
yeah but she said pushed aside but not
for no reason okay next story quite
interesante Facebook's hopes users will
log on and look for love with a new
dating feature I've heard about this
okay I want to go through what this
means because I kind of think it's
genius
no it's I'm torn because I just don't
want like Mark Zuckerberg owning another
piece of the universe like this is just
such a good idea that like I do think
it'll be really successful if it's when
you think about every dating app that
you use it pulls from Facebook like you
always want to know like who your mutual
friends are what their interests are
like it helps to normalize this digital
personality so it's genius that Facebook
should be owning that idea but it freaks
me out because I just I can't have any
more Mark Zuckerberg in my life right
now I used it Iraq
Mark Zuckerberg already owns like and
controls our mind now he will own and
control our hearts Wow very scary very
well said thank you
it was a stumbled out of me that I got
it it's official the company is moving
into dating scene the Facebook dating a
service that will pair users up based on
location listed interests and Facebook
activities launched in the US on
Thursday it is the first time the
company has officially entered the
matchmaking services business stateside
although users have been long using apps
like Instagram as unofficial dating
tools I'll write the announcement comes
at an interesting time for Facebook
which is facing scrutiny about its
privacy practices from the government
and the public now here's what I found
to be interesting about Facebook dating
they are going to match you with people
who have like-minded interests and
aren't live nearby
friends that you're not friends with but
you have mutual friends with yeah
potentially but like that you're not
Facebook friends with but sometimes
there's a Facebook friend that like you
you know know from high school or
something and like you want to match
with them so they will allow you to send
like a secret crush to a person that you
are friends with and then that person
can respond and you'll see if it's
mutual oh that's cute so it's really
it's really cute I think this is so
genius you cut out that like all those
dating apps that rely they might've just
put like a lot of people out of business
they might there are a lot of like great
dating apps where the profiles are super
in-depth and they're you learn a lot
about someone and you're looking for
something super specific but there are a
lot that are just general location likes
on Facebook that's also just like people
think one [ __ ] yeah Facebook I don't
think will be like a [ __ ] platform so
those will always exist because people
always want to [ __ ] yeah I think there's
like something more permanent about
Facebook you know I actually I think
it's a great idea I just wonder if it'll
be successful because I feel like
Facebook has recently launched like a
bunch of ventures that are like not
successful like I say I think it's a way
to get also younger people back on
Facebook maybe like my likes on Facebook
are not applicable with what I like like
in real life I forgot what I even like
so now I have to go back and revamp it
in order to like make a right you want
your profile to be cute yeah are you
gonna join murder no I don't think that
this is her young that young people
would use this like I think young people
like their apps they like swiping they
like the gamified this is gonna like
single parents this is good for older
people who by the way are the people who
are still investing and uploading
pictures on their profile and you know
writing happy birthday to their friends
like you know I would say probably
thirty thirty and up because below
thirty like us and don't even touch me
like I don't I don't take a picture and
say I've got to add this to my album I
don't haven't uploaded a Facebook like
to my mobile uploads like in five years
right like maybe if they did this with
Instagram that's how you we get young
people yes people keep up and take care
of their Instagram profiles but maybe
that's the next phase um but I think
this is like I see old people using this
and I'm really excited for them meet you
oh man that's [ __ ] precious precious
like you could connected with someone
from your high school reunion
there's so many dating um platforms now
like the specificities out of control
like for for farmers yeah for
farmersonly.com oh thank you yes Chris
you may go like there's just
I can't believe there's not like you
know blondes Anonymous you know like you
only want to meet bomb people like
there's specificity of these dating
platforms it's getting a little out of
control
yeah but it's good I think there's more
love than ever how beautiful are more
[ __ ] than ever which works to a which
works to mebut
a snitch a hey okay are you ready for a
fifth and final story hmm am i ready to
talk to Becca Tobin yeah okay this is a
follow-up from our story from yesterday
and just an overall conversation around
vaping because now that it's killing
people the Washington Post has released
that a contaminant found in marijuana
vaping products has been linked to
deadly lung illnesses tests show so
they're starting to suss out what about
vaping is killing people interested we
talking so you know what actually I got
this story for my newsletter and they
summed it up in a really easy to digest
sort of like what you need to know oh
right I check it every morning before I
wake up and that's where I got some
interesting biz news story where should
we start a newsletter like this is the
newsletter I know but the newsletters
are like a moment like there's money in
newsletters let us know should we start
a newsletter yeah cuz I beloved this
newsletter they said federal and state
health officials are zeroing in on a
chemical that they believe may be linked
to a rash of severe lung illnesses from
vaping the chemical is a derivative of
vitamin E called vitamin E acetate and
it was found in the samples of marijuana
taking from seven taken from several
people who got sick or died after vaping
cannabis oil vitamin E acetate is a
common nutritional supplement that's
harmless when swallowed but may be
potentially toxic when vaporized and
inhaled so this I just want to say that
this doesn't actually tell us anything
about Julie right this is a value this
is about we'd pet yes I thought we're
harmless like weed is legal and it's
medicinal yeah so maybe like just that
the idea of taking it in a pen is not
good of vaping it yes so maybe just like
go back to like rolling up a big fatty
or a bowl yeah a bowl or a bong yeah
yeah hit that bottle delicious Kush ever
ripped a bong I don't think so
I'm not it that I can remember I did one
said I was not okay I feel like I've had
to have because after all it's been like
Oh
boom I did it once it was like this tall
glass bong and I that's what about you
know plastic once it was a like a fancy
was like it was one that would could
kill you with one rip like I was on this
couch gripping onto this couch into your
life like I thought I was on a ship I
was on the Titanic and this couch was
like my life raft it was the worst
scariest and my life like I'm not good
like with drugs like that like I was
freaking out in this apartment like
clutching to the to the couch for dear
life like and he was like lash it all
night I was like sweating between my
boobs I was having heart problems like
never again but that's just so you
because you like make stuff haven't
panic like even on a sober I am NOT a
good weed smoker like now I see people
who like it's such a big part of their
lives I'm like [ __ ] jealous I'm like
how late like you just like light up a
doobie and like hang in your house and
you know to go anywhere like you're
having fun like I wish it like every now
and then me and Ben could like spark it
up
I am the worse I'm already I go to bed
when Ben's not here I'm like there's
someone in the house there's someone
squatting behind my bathroom mirror like
I'm crazy like I can only imagine I'm
pod like I would be next level paranoid
so I think it's best just like for
everyone that I I stay away yeah well I
just wanted to be sad like I really want
to you know yeah we know but like that
that's the thing for a lot of people I
read that in Howard Stern's book like he
can smoke pop really and so crazy
paranoid and wonder like how many times
you've referenced Howard Stern's books
did you read it like and every time you
do it's like full of an interesting fact
why not a kid rock thing you told me
yesterday and the plane patron that time
slash the morning toast and the books
really long so it's like not everyone
will have time to read it but I'm giving
you the interesting nuggets you know
that is it interesting nugget and also
another interesting area about these
wheat pens
yes so I'm not saying like Julius a fry
any means but they're parsing out their
got their ears parse and they're
figuring out what killed two people and
it's something that is found in the
marijuana
pens but it's not that I wanna it's the
pen right yeah it's the idea except
activated even oil yes like you may need
that vitamin E thing to make it into an
oil I'm not a scientist
yes I mean I am but but so that's what
we know today before we bring our champ
Becca Tobin I have two announcements
that I need to say one I'm going to be
an Austin next Friday September 30
and so you should come because there's
literally 20 tickets left but in order
to sell those 20 tickets I want to you
know really tease you guys with the fact
that all force teens are gonna be in
Austin like I can't leave we just pull
together this team really ups teens oh
[ __ ] yes we are
no husband's like I came over just like
pulled up this like getaway trip like
more of us I know it's gonna be [ __ ]
let's like you better come to the Austin
show tickets available at girl good job
calm now we are going to take a quick
break rejigger some things and we will
be back with the one the only Becca
Tobin if you have a question for her
drop it in the live stream drop it on
our Instagram picture of her we are so
excited to talk to her
go get a snack don't take too long head
over to girl matchup curls on job calm
get tickets to the Austin show to only
take a few minutes and just by then when
you're clicking purchase we'll be back
bye
you
welcome back to William McKinley High
School today is the best day of my life
you're joined with our second lady gang
member of the week and third Glee cast
member true really
yeah head Jenna and Kevin oh yeah I
promoted their podcast which is a lady
gang Network yes
yeah show yeah please welcome Becca
Tobin hi guys oh my gosh this is the
best day of our lives like we are both
individually obsessed with you like
because I think Jackie and I mean you
can speak for yourself because I am like
truly I'm speechless I am a Gleek like I
am [ __ ] obsessed with Lea ivory watch
it like six hundred times but I also
like her real yeah and it's also a great
show to binge watch on Netflix a it
changed me as a woman like when it was
on TV like I was in high school I was a
target demo for the show yeah and you
like it was just everything and then you
like charge into like our podcasting
role model and like please I just think
there's like so many layers to you you
know no seriously no I bullied you into
having me today no do you like by the
way we don't know that every too young
for Fashion Week cuz we donated by the
tiny fashion week I don't either
so we were like we have so many guests
this week like more than usual just
because it gets like everyone's in town
that you're hopping by shows that are
you know Fashion Week I mean adjacent
okay I try to avoid New York during
Fashion Week because it's horrible
horrible meanest people the worst kinds
coming to get blood this city and so I
try to avoid it but somehow something
happens that I have to go to around the
same time and I was like I don't [ __ ]
go so how long are you here for till
Saturday
okay yes I stayed to see my best friends
in Moulin Rouge on Broadway oh I heard
it was so good right yeah that's really
good and so I wouldn't see that last
night that's fun yeah okay so I don't
even know where to begin with you
because this is what we were saying to
Kelty it's like every member of the lady
gang has just like I wouldn't even know
what to call you like you are truly a
quadruple threat
actor singer dancer podcaster a TV TV
star now well I mean star is super
generous so thank you so much or eyes
you are a TV star you as in my parents
we don't that is nice
loved lady gang season was season one we
thought it was such a great way to
translate from like podcasting to
television which is not easy now and
there are many a digital people who have
like gotten a TV platform and just like
change today
you're in it for the rest of us it's
tough so what was that process like of
like going from not having to wearing
makeup recording a podcast like being a
full-fledged production the makeup part
was was shitty yeah I just started
getting in at 5:00 a.m. I mean I'm
wearing eight million pounds of makeup
now but it was like 10 times this right
it was tonight's TV lights and it's hard
cuz it's your baby it's like you guys
you start something and it's just the
three of us and we're super precious
about it because I've been like a
dancing monkey my whole life and I just
do and say and seeing what other people
tell me too so for the first time I was
like oh this is this is my voice this is
my responsibility to like not be a
douche bag it's a big one
I didn't I didn't meet up to that it's
fine and so having all the cooks in the
kitchen was it was tough yeah I'm super
collaborative and like the network was
really great and championed us to just
be ourselves I mean we were a little too
much I didn't think so really I
appreciate job yeah it's there when you
were following busy tonight which is
like the worst show ever like you had to
separate yourself with yeah it had to be
done Injection yeah I and they tried and
I feel like I like knew about your bread
before but watching the show like I know
I know everything yeah you know yeah I
mean you think you know everything right
there's still a tune well so you guys
have been doing the show Kelsey was here
she said four years of the podcast yeah
do you feel like at any point we will
run out of things to talk about we're
all naturally the biggest fear we're
like one thing we won't have stories to
tell her things that said no because you
guys are interesting people with good
with opinions I think that people that
are smart with opinions you'll never
stop running out and you have to do I
think that Joan Rivers said something
along the lines of like I'm in a butcher
the [ __ ] out of this so please don't
even check this maybe even made it up I
dreamed it I don't know but something
like you know everyone ages out of this
industry like you get old and ugly and
fat and like I just but if you have an
opinion and something to say like people
can't take that away from you
you're bad I know what you're what is it
if you have six good
minutes you will never you will always
be able to work like you will always
have a job if you have six kids I have
something to say maybe that's it I don't
even [ __ ] I just watched a
documentary like the greatest thing ever
I mean greatest person this makes the
five year anniversary of my passing and
like it just doesn't get easier it's too
fresh it's so shitty you know I haven't
thought about you today when I was
thinking like what ha no Beckett oh
because like I actually like I'm just
like so excited I'm like got a shark I'm
not leaving no yes
do you feel like maybe in like five or
six years like you would ever be a real
housewife of Beverly Hills I feel like
that would be a great job because of how
I'm dressed today no I just thought
about you like you but everything else
you have such an interesting life and
I'm so relevant like thank you but I'm
I'm too broke to be on the Housewives of
Beverly know that's an interesting
they're also rich I mean oh sees a
bummer yeah it's a bummer and it's like
you're left to your New Jersey like in
your house is in foreclosure Jersey I
here's the thing it's like don't never
meet your heroes totally I don't want to
get behind the curtain of that show I
love it so much like I feel so
passionate about the New York City
housewives same I I don't like some
Bethenny leaving I'm upset tragic I'm
upset but I also improve her because
she's doing some good [ __ ] yeah yeah
stable and down the mission it's insane
like I donated you should just say to
die it's so it makes me feel better like
yeah like I'm guilt like a community
where your money is going yeah and you
know she's not [ __ ] around no got it
Oh like if the woman is willing to get
on a plane herself and like get down
there and get in the whatever the [ __ ]
is happy just yeah and if she's just
amazing I'm gonna miss her a lot but
really Sonja Morgan is I see that
actually I see you to shine even better
I feel like you should definitely make
it like a thing for you to find her
tonight I've announced it tonight yeah
like it's your last night New York
you're home in Saturday's I mean I would
I wouldn't make it home tomorrow she
takes a party in the town well not
anymore to the tenants but every
Wednesday I pee like a Kiki I love I'm
happy for her like that she's getting
the cash flow and has a new place and I
hope she does paint those walls pink
so I mean she's amazing okay I want to
talk to you about something that's like
kind of controversial and when Kevin and
Jen right here we spoke to him about it
too and I'm not sure if you know about
like the conspiracy theory that took the
world by storm oh my god that via
Michelle can't read I knew and Michelle
are the best of friends each other's
weddings yeah so you wouldn't know if
she can't okay I would know and I
remember when this was going on and I
had dinner with her she thought it was
the funniest but she read the menu
that's what a special right yes she
heard it she couldn't she couldn't read
she's actually one of the most
intelligent people that I've ever met
gradual intelligent people can also not
be readers that's right but she reads a
lot of books
no actually read you watch the video the
power presentation and she's like they
crush this video and then the right
Murphy element that like he works with
her because she's the only one who knows
her secret like the thing that makes a
lot of sense
yeah it was the greatest conspiracy that
I've ever heard but you are debunking it
I unfortunately I have to I mean I've
seen the girl read you know I believe
went to school now I'm just all over the
place because I just have had things to
talk to you about my whole like you are
wedding yeah was so [ __ ] beautiful
like it and you know that your wedding
video was it on Brides yes it like
always it's all over my youtube like a
bunch of all times a week it's so
beautiful is it in Aspen somewhere
little in Jackson Hole yes yeah yeah
[ __ ] beautiful thank you yeah I feel
like I totally got to know your style
like who you are just been watching that
video I'm like stalking the bride
something thank you do you like being
married I love being married good way
yeah but I hated being a bride hey we're
the same time airs worse than ever it's
the worst and I also don't have a single
memory from my wedding same because I
blacked out like not from alcohol know
him from stress and pain and anxiety and
like I it was the worst night one should
be a bride I agree yeah just word house
elope all the way do it well so being
Jackie out again are
sister Olivia got engagin we were like
[ __ ] get this done like I was engaged
for 15 months Jackie was engaged for a
year she got married four months genius
yeah I want you to take questions from
the toasters because we got it right we
got such a wide array of questions via
tempers and there's one that I just saw
that truly made me laugh and I would
love to hear your opinion on this this
is from join Nets okay looking back how
do you feel about the episode where
there was carbon monoxide leak and
thinks everyone is a puppet what are you
actually now like I said artists what do
you think about that join that first of
all I barely remember they actually lead
car but we're very method yeah I kind of
remember it I wait I do remember okay we
became puppets yeah yeah I had like cute
puppets of each of you yeah that we
couldn't [ __ ] keep I don't know but
that's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] Fox
probably auction them off yeah I'm
thanks I'm using something bullsh I
would bought it he was so cute my puppet
yeah um that was the only thing I really
remember I think what season was that it
was not a good one yeah I lost it a
little bit at the end um yeah I was
mostly just excited for the puppets cuz
I thought I'd have a souvenir one single
super from the show do you have any
souvenirs I have this is embarrassing
but I'll tell you I have my Cheerios
uniform one of the like 50 that I had
good good in shadow box yeah yeah dad
study Oh
China was a cheerio for Halloween I was
like that's how influenced I was did you
because you got in the show what like
season four yeah did you ever go on the
tour no I mean Jenna and Kevin were
telling us it was their calcia she's
like yeah
like this it was the best night of our
lives one of the first concerts we went
to like we were [ __ ] living we have
to find those photos of us I'm like a
berry blackberry at Nassau Coliseum I
got the night of our lives
I know all I heard I came on the season
the last summer they did that I started
right after and they were all like they
hated it shells of humans yeah yeah they
didn't get a break that's all of it
that's that's what they said yeah um
this is a great question from Hannah Oh
Kelly
Bing Mary Kim it's just you play there's
so much and I changed my answer I know
but this one I can guarantee mr. Shue
Burt Hummel Kurt's dad oh my god
Principal Figgins okay okay
[ __ ] well I mean I feel like Burt Hummel
would be good in the sack I mean oh why
seems like a provider like first fiddle
he owns a mechanic yeah I agree he did
know about giving up his son I liked him
and he's also so successful and so
talented yes he was he was that the face
of that commercial the insurance company
for years produces and writes a ton of
[ __ ] oh yeah his commercials are pretty
crazy I know until he was like the face
of a major national campaign he's huge
no I would have sex with him because I
would want to see what that was like you
know yeah I feel like seeing Matt
Morrison dance I know what he's gonna be
like in bed I'm not disappointing yeah
but not a surprise I feel like he was my
least favorite character like both on
and off screen Maria I think he was the
worst like the only issue I had with
Glee was that he was miscast like he was
supposed to be this like warm relatable
guy and I found him to be irritatingly
annoying really yeah like I felt about
him the way Sue Sylvester felt about his
butt chin and his curly hair like I got
what she was like she was oh oh yeah
yeah and I got why she was so mean to
the glee club because you're like I
stole her guiding weight but here's what
I have to say about mr. Shue so I grew
up I I can't I lived in New York and I
did the whole Broadway thing before Glee
and when I was young like in high school
still like reaching for that dream you
know I went and saw hairspray on
Broadway and Matt Morrison played link
Mark miscast again no I'm telling you my
vagina was sopping well
I he was so dreamy like I live madly in
love with him oh my god I sort of got to
end him oh yeah I had a crazy crazy
thing and I don't feel that way about
most men right away I'm Brad my starting
with when I start working with him I
like made the mistake as we got to know
each other very well I told him and so
then he would like to things like wink
at me yeah
so I'm pious okay it's my one of my
first loves I can't believe it's taken
us like 20 minutes to bring this up and
I blame you because Jackie is yes a home
number-one fan I got it made it on the
official hallmark podcast yes I'm so
excited I'm Ty Jackie that I saw a
commercial for a movie that you were in
and then she watched it yeah and it's my
dream to like be in like an extra in a
Hallmark felt absolutely and I just
would like to know like how is the
experience I've done three now and I
should for you Judah paid a lot or a
little for a hallmark movie because so
many like celebrities done their name to
it that you would think it would be a
lot I'm gonna just tell you that it's
like one of the most well performing
networks on TV yes yogi is dying right
linear TVs yeah
the hallmark is good yeah in a great
place and the movies are [ __ ] good
the movies are good people love them and
I'm telling you I get stopped more for
homework movies than anything really
yeah I've done three now I do like one a
year usually and it's kind of the most
great it's what am I the most great it's
the greatest experience I love that the
network they take care of you they treat
you like a princess I'm like I'm like
nobody gets treated like this anymore
right and I don't know it's just so fun
and you are like so hallmark like you're
so cute looking like I think you should
do more I'm not quite Homer yes you are
about gross things like my panties like
perfect like hallmark needs you
I think that I push the boundaries a
little bit and I but I what I hope that
they're seeing is that I'm bringing like
these late
right to the network and they are now
standing hallmark because like me yeah
um but I love it and that's a whole new
demographic for them
exactly and you just went on tour with
the lady gangers that the lady hang yeah
guys like some odd you are a touring
machine machine and also tickets
available [ __ ] every venue out well
you know it's taken some time but yes
crash it's honestly I can't take any
credit for like it's toasters like they
like lifts me up and come to see you
this shows like great to the Jarls my
job back I could develop I need to see
it yeah you do I'm gonna be a night
October 13th tickets available can I
calm please okay great thank you I got
one for you touring it's fun but it's
hard and but it the like the greatest
part about it is getting to see all the
girls and actually meet them yes you do
the podcast and you're so in your own
little like bubble bubble that getting
out there and seeing that these girls
exist and they're real and Kelty isn't
just writing in questions for some would
you rather books cuz she she hijacked
your show the other day by the way she
was we were so great so many like we
have like a list of episodes like that
we if you're ever trying to get someone
to become a toaster like if we're
everything like the greatest episodes
that really like encompass like the
culture of you're using that and we make
it is healthy to the list yeah just a
great guest segment it's really elevated
us like as a real host you know she is a
[ __ ] hustler like she was making me
tired just like talking about Lisa Rinna
vibes yes I was getting those vibes
watching her on the team really yes she
broke her foot I saw her her foot is
[ __ ] huge it's broke and she's
meeting up with like an old boss and she
was running late and she was running
across the street at her Louboutin got
oh my god wide leg pant and she took a
tumble and her foot is broken oh my god
those new Louboutins they did her dirty
I know that was so nice too okay
you know she's still working more from
Instagram Brennan Thomas Welsh
where were you when you found out that
you got the part in Glee I was actually
home and it
visiting my parents for some reason I
had been I was living in New York at the
time and I just like got the call I was
home by myself and my parents house and
I got the call anti-climactic
it really is and then we celebrated at
the Waffle House ideal ideal that's a
party we need Waffle House um from betta
shokran how does junior husband meet you
guys are so cute together um thank you
we met years and years and years ago he
went to college with a bunch of my
friends we just had like friends in
common such a nice way to meet someone
his and for like 10 years he asked my
best friend every time we saw her if I
was single oh my god I love him yeah and
I never was cuz I'm you know it's a hot
commodity you were truly like every
kitty and thank you how did you feel
about the singular curl they put your
hair not great I'm just gonna such a
cute look but I can imagine it was like
[ __ ] annoying like do you know
twisting it no do you know like that was
a real issue for me amazing nothing
breaks down a girl's self-esteem more
than the hair more thin asleep back Pony
and a minimal make-up completely yeah
like it curl I did a single curl yeah
yeah interesting choice and it was
before hair extensions right it was real
it was real and so it was sad and limp
just like a sad yeah okay and it's Ryan
loves a signature look yeah he really it
was really iconic like and also if that
signature look was established on Naya
Rivera it's not fair she's an alien but
it is beautiful right and she could do
anything and then I come in looking like
a potato and I like it was signature and
I was like looking from here every day
this is my television debut well that's
the hardest part about acting it's like
you're under someone else's creative
like yeah I'm like no I would like a
beach wave we don't have any sort of my
background it was serious Brad Falchuk
turn end of the series I was like I had
had enough like my hair was breaking oh
and I just needed that ponytail out of
my head and a little was vanity tail
yeah of course and I emailed Brad
serious emails being like hey Brad um
I was wondering if you could approve
just a trim like a hair treatments but
sensible trim like just short enough to
not do obscene growth maybe didn't
answer it you might be too busy falling
in love oh yeah but Glee was just the
home base of like so much iconic like
mother chin yeah exactly yeah it's great
what was did you film the episodes with
Quinn Paltrow yeah yeah she's she was
iconic if you ask me for a million
dollars yeah remember she sank Turning
Tables in the auditorium by Joe oh my
gosh she's got a great voice
she's the coolest person to ever see
Country Strong um did I are you we hope
you to soundtrack on vinyl you can have
it already hi stopping coming home at
Jackie's wedding no oh my god that is
the most underrated movie
I completely it's just ours more Eva
better is yes yes yeah you know what
else is great the Johnny Cash well
online walk the line it's like those
movies that had a little more like
excitement around Oscar she won for that
yeah yeah Wow
I know and when it was robbed she was
robbed but she's been to watch its soup
Orton speaking of music you've a banger
yeah don't I know it
I think it's just a fun good feel I love
it
I am so jealous it was you shoot him out
with the song hmm
your friend Lea came out with a [ __ ]
bang she she her songs come up on my
shuffle and I will never know what's
this on she sing on American Idol
cannonball no with that girl who would
roll name journey with like the rainbow
hair it's the best song ever and I watch
our performance on YouTube right after I
watch your wedding video yeah like
multiple times a week it's the best song
I her solo music yeah she's doing a
Christmas album oh that's so it it's
gonna be great yeah like I have
something refreshing are you doing a
Christmas hallmark movie
as of now no but it's not too late it's
never too it's never too late and like
Christmas that goes through like Jackie
goes till Valentine's Day for a Hallmark
Channel yeah it's just like what we need
so there's yeah yeah how long does it
take to shoot one three-ish weeks
that's a nice time wick where'd you
shoot Canada for two and then Palm
Springs for the last one which was
amazing right yeah yeah I'm into
bringing film back to the States
yeah I mean I love Canada of course I
lost Haneda but like I also love being
home because this is you know the we're
pretty salacious I just need you to
spill some to you for me let her give me
one bit of information like something
that you might not have known about like
the Glee like denier of Araby foot Lea
Michele like wasn't real was it not I'm
telling something I need to leave it was
something tangible oh god this is so
hard because the show was really like
such a cultural moment yeah and there
was so much talk around it and about it
like you didn't know like what was real
what was not then tell me that crazy
things happens like between Cory and the
marks Taylor yeah but all like there was
a lot going on there I mean here's the
thing is I don't remember I never really
like saw what was out there so now I'm
gonna say something and if it wasn't
already out there is no [ __ ] but I
honestly I cannot think of anything that
like is that juicy was it was it like
what do people hear what it was
here's the thing I joined after the
majority of the drama like I came in
after everybody had dated after
everybody had like thought every like
and it's young people put together and
then like shot to stardom shocked into
stardom and the only people that had
ever even like had any little tiny bit
of not same but like career was like Lea
who started as a baby and Jane Lynch the
hardest working women in television I
can't even I love her so is she
everything she's everything I just moved
so she officiated your wedding she did
that is like the most uninteresting
finest fashion I know is I mean I talk
about her every time I do anything so
she's probably like restraining order
she's also my neighbor yes
I just she's amazing she she is the most
special human ever I my first day on set
was with her a scene with her and I was
like I've never done TV before I came
from Broadway and I they literally gave
me a week to break my lease and move
like Oh to get out to LA and be on TV I
didn't even know what a mark was like I
didn't know you had to stand on a mark
like it was really stressful and then
they're like oh and your first scene is
with Jane Lynch I'm like I'm gonna die
on the set of Glee without ever even
speaking but I never eat without never
getting paid that didn't even happen
till the end I had to [ __ ] put some
time in no but Jane sits down next to me
in her little cash chair and we're
waiting to go in she's so nice she's
like scrolling on her phone I don't know
why I'll never forget this and they're
like okay ready for ready for actors and
she's like hang on one second I'm
ordering a tankini oh my god that's so
relatable it shows it was Sylvester
Joe's sister kisser rocks a tankini it
was amazing I like broke the tension
immediately oh my god how was arguing
with Nene
how is she on yeah actually one episode
with me Roz Washington are not well that
was I Stan that time period I was but
like weirdly being from Atlanta I'm not
really in Atlanta house when I just got
into it it's the best franchise like
you're sleeping on it I used to watch it
a lot
me too same and then I fell off and then
too much happened and I couldn't now
it's good no I I don't know like you
know history I know but the history is
that Nene was on Glee and then she was
on that other when you show her mall and
she really thought she was too good for
everyone she was asking me to everyone
move to LA and then she had to come back
any chip because her acting is like my
trajectory it all came both actually
it's really good now and they they have
a Atlanta like whenever other franchises
get new housewives like it really very
rarely works yeah Atlanta housewives
that they constantly bring in are
interesting okay all right fine I'll
watch and yes Nene was everything that I
was expecting she is like larger than
life yeah um it's always a show
she doesn't power down yeah it didn't
seem yes I think she got along with
everyone I think so
I didn't I think I had one episode with
her that was it I'm talking over a
holiday role I was like yeah this girl
actually might have a career as an
actress and she was great on new normal
all so many bright that was a great chef
that's why Ryan Murphy so brilliant like
just seeing something and Nene that
she'd even see him herself
he's like finally but that was such a
great casting and she was so good and
she [ __ ] scared me she was at the
scary swim coach and she went toe to toe
with sue and principal thinkit's I
hadn't watch this it was the best GJ you
were telling us before you started the
this stream that you did not actually
watch episodes that you were on but you
did watch a show before I watched no I
didn't watch the show before I watched a
couple of them and then on season four
when I joined every week we'd have
screenings during lunch so you'd kind of
be forced to see the show it was on
she's like be there with everybody at
Paramount there's like a big screening
room but then season five and six like I
just stopped watching because I was
going to the plastic surgeon too often
and not doing anything but toying with
it I just was like I don't want to see
myself from all the angles
I don't the screen is huge and I just
I'm okay you know I feel that I'm okay I
don't need to I don't know if I was ever
on the show if I would watch it yeah
like we do a show every day you don't
never watch it no you can't I kind of
think that also I like the memory of
being there shooting it with all the
people yeah better than what comes out
of you know the end result like I see
the factory and how the sausage is made
I'm ready to also see the sausage I get
it I get it
thank you so people not watching
he will definitely Lobster definitely
dirty hands I'll tell you that because
you're such a triple threat but now
you've quadruple threat into podcasting
and this is simply something I struggle
with it as a podcaster how do you just
stop yourself and like breaking out into
song on your podcast I'm not that person
oh you're not you want Lee I know but
like I'm illiterate oh they didn't she
you know what that's what happened I I
mean I'm such a musical theater dork I
grew up singing all the time everywhere
but I don't know I just you don't do it
on the pocket healthy does it so much I
think I need to like stay at a certain
level she goes we let her fly now do
your listeners like the singing because
I've gotten a lot of flack for my
singing I actually watched the episode
where you discussed this it's just a
target but it's an audio thing it's not
yeah I know I know it's for Kelty it's
both her voice is wretched oh look like
Gretchen not all of she and I have been
competing for six months about who's
gonna get the offer to play Roxie Hart
on Broadway first definitely not
Broadway like you do I've never been on
a few shows and I just got the vibe it's
not her
yeah she's gonna fight for it and she
might actually get it cuz this is what
happened because she's like yeah she
gets she makes things happen that we
never thought possible would I go back
to a show um I'd love to go right to New
York I could do New York but you just
moved into a house yeah but like I love
coming to New York I love having an
excuse to be here yeah I hate being in
New York not having a job yeah so
there's no way that I wouldn't you have
like seven jobs you really we need to
talk about how we met - because I wonder
if each other and we went to an
influencer dinner with her black before
influencer dinners for a thing and like
they were fancy like revolve like
flowers you know yeah we were the
original revolve where were right I'm
you should get back to that restaurant
it's on the west side 23rd and like
11:00 I would never remember the name of
their Jack he brought me and I was like
no I wanna go [ __ ] back Tobin's going
yeah really I'm going down and who the
guy sent me Beckett open so I was like
okay
bless you I see you thank you you guys
were like too cool for me I thought
dinner I was no you don't want to be my
friend we were so nervous and we to the
picture we have to find that picture oh
yeah that was before I started penciling
in my eyebrows I think I Jamie got it
surrounded what year was the ID of
instagrammed it oh I was big so that was
like 2015 I was like really big I caged
my yeah I'm like 2014 oh right I was
what you had it was April 2015 cuz I
remember what he's like he was like a
really cute like Union Jack sequin dress
yeah it's like that I still wear that
sheesh coca-cola oh yeah and it's a cute
cute but it's not flattering and I was
like I'm an honest my biggest but on my
way down and like my biggest was
February of that year and my smallest
was like August so it was around April I
hope you are that's that's how I
remember I know totally I'm like a steel
trap putty has the worst memory I suffer
from memory loss okay like I am what is
that I don't know I call my friend who's
a neurologist every week and I tell her
I think that I have early dementia
that's what I've had early onset
dementia 1,000% I think I do too but
then I smoke weed so I'm like is it the
weed oh not anymore because of your
entire well nothing I can do from a pen
yeah but I like the pen I know maybe
easier so much nicer it would be Larry
Snoop Dogg and like roll the joint now
oh yeah it's kind of gangster scary
anything have to like smoke the whole
joint yeah but we'll see how my memory
gets now that I'm not but she doesn't
smoke weed and her memory sucks so maybe
it's not related okay you guys I can't
find it okay
this is so annoying because also I'm
doing what Kelsey did with the Enneagram
what is your nickname only podcast and
the other day was like oh that's so
three of you or something she said that
I was like I'm dead
we're the worst humans on the planet I
think I'm also a three but I think I'm
an undercover three I feel like there's
different like variants within each
number yeah
that makes it
careless I don't really care what people
think so much I mean have my mom have I
care too much you you it's it's actually
like a crippling disability like ah
nobody is like it's it ruins everything
that I do because I'm I'm always like
projecting what people are gonna say
before they even say you know like it's
awful but you still do it
yes you're like super gangster like that
well I think she's like torturing
herself I know but I'm also like having
cancer yeah you have at the time I'm
like I don't give a [ __ ] what anyone
says I'm and women the other half of the
time I'm like in my bed crying about me
on Twitter you know yeah I didn't turn
on the photo so I couldn't find it like
someone has said okay I had well the
image could influence our dinner before
it was a thing we're a sunglass company
right yeah yeah so my friend that I grew
up with from million years ago started
this it was Reds ready yet I wasn't
about that was truly just a plus-one I
was really just invited to be an
influencer and I didn't know we were
sitting with a kajillion when like not
two years ago we were at the Glee
concert in Nassau Coliseum like it was
truly like it is that it was an amazing
moment for us well I'm glad it was good
for you because I thought you guys were
[ __ ] oh we were so nervous and in
hindsight like it was good for us I
think then like we had the biggest pits
and I didn't like talking neither to
each other I like being like immature
probably like wait I think I was doing
something inappropriate at that dinner
so I was like there was a girl that that
guy who said the dinner up was dating
and she was very do you remember she was
like really buttoned up my dementia like
like don't even I don't
she was ringing like a legit ribbon in
her hair
no Mac it was a starting some Members
Only Club in New York she was so country
club Upper East Side
she was really and when I'm around
people like that I get super
uncomfortable like it's awkward for me
when people aren't just saying
inappropriate things yeah yeah and so I
just have to push the envelope in those
situations and I made her super super
uncomfortable and I just remember I left
that Zack my husband was my boyfriend at
the time and he's like why do you why do
you have to do that what you there yeah
my brain is like it's so sad you've done
such good thing and I don't even
remember oh yeah
I only remember weird things like that
remember that but like I can't remember
what I ate yesterday
for a million dollars I don't know I
[Laughter]
just don't want to let you go like I
don't say we were chatting I mean no I
think we told her everything I think she
was simulations that we stand we stay at
the altar everything I've done not
literally mean no just like I'd like to
all the Cheerios you know Quinn like
she's cool whatever but like kitty was
much for me and I really felt there so
like we never got to know more about her
than they might wind up to Ryder that
kid he was sexually assaulted and let me
never they never wanted that deeper in
yeah there there was no follow-up but I
also think like what would that
follow-up look I don't know what it was
just like to see him worry with my child
psychologist you know show me on the
graph where he touched J that's not
appropriate you know as a kids show for
sure was it April 2015
she said yeah it's April wasn't it bro
you are a nice man sir amen
oh my wait turn around we got a long
wait that's so weird my hair was so long
Jackie you were big you had a different
handle you were big - oh he's done
you had a different you know which was
gonna be my next question because was
you it was back back go back
yeah yeah but you secured Becca and
Kelty for you yeah and so are you able
to help us I have like a couple right no
nothing
well I we have a social media girl
that's like the social media maven of
Los Angeles and she just handled it for
us her name is Callie Mickey to mention
which is something social okay we need I
will connect um what are you rebrand
just me Jackie O like I want to drop the
problem Jackie
Oh might be tough I know well I know
I've seen the girl who has it and she's
just like a regular girl or a night like
message her and she refuses to open it
she said she was the last time she
posted if she's active [ __ ] I think she
just got married and there is div yeah
yes that's how I got mine okay one more
question before we let you go um I
didn't know if this was something that
like I felt when I was watching the show
but I was listening all the toasters
leave comments for you and it's a parent
that we all felt the same way about
Marley that she was just like actually
the words character like you were so
evil to her and I don't I don't endorse
what you did Tara cuz like you really
[ __ ] with her mind her size that she
never found out that you did all that
said also yeah yeah I think the but a
more submit it was awful like obviously
but that character was so [ __ ]
annoying like she got so famous
afterwards like she went on to be
Supergirl yes Supergirl yeah and she was
in the CW playing all the time like
would be friends with her yeah oh hey
she's always taking a [ __ ] yeah she's
always with them so tell me about her
offline she's great she's super talented
she is I think that here's the thing
like going into that show and they
called her episode the new Rachel that
was the name of the first episode no
yeah sure yeah exactly and like Leah's
character was iconic I mean and by the
way like there's no there's no Rachel
Berry and so it's like hard that she was
sort of set up to for the fans he
disliked yeah we kind of all were I mean
I'll never forget they they like didn't
something with a press release with like
our new photos and someone wrote on the
bottom of mine on somewhere like who's
this 40 year old housewife dress
they were predicting your future right
really what I'm like at the time like I
know yeah right but you were so
frustrated so how old were you when you
started late 25 are you looked 15 thank
you
oh but seeing that before you even start
so and I was like a side character she
was like coming in to take over that
crushed me for a good day right good by
the way she that's I I firmly believe
like she have it you know a big part
inverting the show
no like I really did not like no I'll
tell you she's really really [ __ ]
talented she can sing she just did
beautiful she's in Broadway she can fly
she is so like she's really an intellect
she's that was a tough situation I feel
like there's a reason why she really
like got super successful afterward it's
like she must be yeah you didn't get to
know where are some of us it's like yeah
I lightning can strike once but good
luck letting it find you like I've been
standing in a field with an umbrella
okay like she's not there's no shortage
for her because she is really talented
super talented okay and then my last
question I know I said the last one was
last one keep going he's Blake Jenner
related to all the other Jenner no I
wish that's too bad yeah I played the
long-haired writer writer yeah yeah yeah
remember he is not related when I went
to college a lot of you guys dropped off
not why I don't have a job I find them
all the way through thank you so your
support in New York thank you okay the
content you put out all the smiles all
the memories I think I speak on behalf
of all of us toasters and litigators
Thank You Becca thank you guys I love
you guys thank you guys for listening to
the morning show some millennial Morning
Show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to subscribe like all that
[ __ ] we're also available as
podcasts to do the same [ __ ] over
there iTunes Spotify leave a review of
five stars about how like we are so
smart and skinny an amazing it's like
can you just like one of us also tickets
available to my to our girl code a
couple being awesome
Friday and then like la Portland Seattle
that Cooper Toronto San Diego San
Francisco you know all this old states
you don't have dementia hit it up not
when it comes to money calm have a great
weekend don't drink and drive bye-bye
you